mesdames et messieurs bonsoir il fera en
général beau demain je donnerais des
détails en fin de journal
mais il fera pas dans la présente
édition nous parlerons du congrès du
parti communiste français à cinq points
de la fin des travaux du tunnel routier
franco italien madan bardonnèche où se
trouvait monsieur bart et vous verrez de
cannes une ligne interview portrait du
célèbre acteur woody allen mais nous
commençons par des nouvelles de
l'allemagne de l'ouest il fait toujours
bon de voir ce que l'on fait chez des
voisins
le parlement a décidé qu'après la
naissance d'un enfant les maires se
verront accorder un congé spécial non
plus de quatre mois
mais de six mois période durant laquelle
elles percevront une somme mensuelle de
1700 francs versés par l'état alors les
mères de famille qui resteront ainsi au
foyer pour s'occuper du bébé libéreront
pendant un temps des emplois féminins
outre mesure et qui fera couler beaucoup
d'encre le parlement allemand a décidé
que les jeunes pourraient dès l'âge de
14 ans choisir librement leur carrière
et leur avenir sans que des parents
puissent s'y opposer
les adolescents auront même des recours
juridiques possibles en cas de conflit
sur ces points avec leur famille qu'est
ce qui a conduit l'allemagne à adopter
cette loi
deux colonnes notre envoyé spécial
permanent michel meyer la loi qui vient
donc d'être adoptée ici est à considérer
comme une sorte de mise à jour il s'agit
d'adapter en quelque sorte une
législation patriarcal qui date du début
de ce siècle aux moeurs actuelles aux
moeurs qui ont considérablement évolué
en allemagne s'il s'agit d'offrir aux
enfants la chance de préparer eux mêmes
leur avenir contre éventuellement la vie
de parent autoritaires ou incapable d'un
minimum de concertation alors
pratiquement que se passera-t-il et bien
à partir de janvier prochain
tous les enfants depuis 14 ans et ce
sera le cas de ma petite fille d'ici
deux ans pourront choisir eux mêmes
l'évolution de leur carrière et leur
métier futur éventuellement contre
l'avis des parents en l'occurrence pour
closing contre mon avis elle pourra
également dans le cas d'un conflit avec
moi même faire appel auprès d'un
tribunal allemand et obtenir de ce
tribunal un soutien
vidic légales pour faire ce qu'elle
souhaite ultérieurement dans le cas d'un
divorce éventuel possible en allemagne
un peu partout eh bien elle pourra à
partir de 14 ans aussi choisir l'endroit
où elle vivra c'est à dire auprès de son
père ou auprès de sa mère voilà un peu
la situation alors j'ai demandé à
claudine qui n'est pas concernée par
cette loi parce qu'elle est française de
faire une petite enquête auprès de ses
amis allemands et allemandes et comment
tes amis ont réagi d'une façon générale
occupait le [ __ ] on dit qu'ils ont été
très surpris mais il trouve que c'est
bon dans les tasses à certains cas pour
ce qu'ils ont des parents inhumains ou
autoritaires ton autoritaire et toi
personnellement que penses tu de ses
toiles tu es d'accord n'ont pas tout à
fait je trouve que c'est un peu gros
elle est juste qu'un procès contre ses
parents pour un métier
oui alors on peut dire que d'une façon
générale pour résumer cette petite
enquête cette mini enquête que les
législateurs sont peut-être aller un peu
plus loin que les moeurs et la
conscience de l'opinion publique
allemande en ce moment dans tous les cas
et c'est ce qui est intéressant en ce
qui concerne cette loi la notion de co
décision de co responsabilité et de
maturité l'égal des plus de 14 ans et
existe l'heure actuelle elle devient
complémentaire à au principe de majorité
légale à 18 ans et je crois que sans
être une révolution c'est quand même une
évolution intéressante et un manifeste
la tendance à la realpolitik qui
caractérise d'une façon générale la
politique allemande notamment sur le
plan social
cette mesure concerne les adolescents
n'est pas approuvée unanimement tant
s'en faut
les allemands estiment par exemple que
l'état intervient maintenant trop dans
les rapports familiaux mais il ya déjà
un pays en europe où une loi à peu près
semblable est appliquée c'est la suède
et martine laroche joubert est allé sur
place pour analyser certaines de ses
conséquences
aujourd'hui en suède
toutes les petites filles son modèle
sophie ryler peut se permettre tous les
malheurs sans risquer le châtiment du
bon petit diable la fessée les députés
ont mis hors la loi les châtiments
corporels sont les enfants qui battu
pourront porter plainte eux mêmes contre
leurs parents beaucoup d'enfants suédois
ne sont pas bien traités du tour et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
promulgué cette loi si nous pensons
qu'il est important de dire que nous
devons bien les traiter leur donner de
l'amour et leur accorder une attention
toute particulière
given interest sort cette loi marque un
point de plus dans un système
d'éducation particulièrement libérale
éducation à la suédoise où l'on cherche
à donner aux enfants les mêmes droits
qu'aux adultes à en faire des citoyens
comme les autres dans l'école de base
pas d'estrade barrière avec les
maîtresses mais des cours dialoguer pas
de redoublement non plus revers de la
médaille il n'est guère facile de punir
la discipline et les premières victimes
en sont quelques fois les professeurs je
ne pense pas que les enfants soient
traités comme des rois
mais plutôt comme des princes ou des
princesses on pense trop peur
est ce que vous pensez qu'il y a assez
de discipline dans les écoles suédoises
n'ont pas assez je préférerais qu'il y
en ait un peu plus ils ne savent pas ce
que le mot respect signifie pleinement
au sens où on l'entendait autrefois
maintenant il faut être une personne
particulièrement intéressante si on veut
être écouté
il ne suffit pas d'être professeur
sophie qui se l'école de base vers 13
heures certains de ses amis passent le
reste de l'après midi dans un centre de
loisirs mais se fit encore son listes
d'attentes rentrer chez elle et a tancé
par en l'absence des parents le père et
la mère travaille souvent tous les lieux
a permis au parlement suédois
d'intervenir de plus en plus dans la vie
des familles d'imposer une éducation
sans fessée mais cette loi ne marque pas
un point final dans la protection des
enfants martyrs ou malheureux oui les
révélant dans les familles on ne voit
pas il ya loi il n'a pas d'importance
c'est pas comme ça qu'on résolve les
problèmes je trouve les enfants des
rentrées consciente de cette loi exige
mais accuse les partisans et les mots
vers les écoles aussi
non mais c'est il faut pénétrer dans les
familles c'est là il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas dans la famille je trouve
il avait province comme avec la mer on
ne
le père par exemple ou d'autres
problèmes c'est ça qui peut donner des
idées et de la violence revient sur les
enfants les temps ont de moins en moins
en est on avec les enfants façon que ce
soit il ya peut-être des heures avec les
enfants quand ils rentrent bien sûr il
veut pas être est ce m r en couleurs
avec les enfants au lieu de ça il laisse
l'image du bonheur à la suédoise se
dessine peu à peu
il n'est pas si facile de trouver un
équilibre entre les droits des enfants
et ceux des parents de protéger les
enfants martyrs sans fard m départ en
martyr le 23ème congrès du parti
communiste rasées à sainte foy en est à
sa quatrième journée et quelques pas de
statistiques il y as presque 2000
délégués dont à peu près un tiers de
femmes les travailleurs employés et
techniciens forme d'un peu plus de 70%
des congressistes dont l'âge moyen est
de 34 au cours de cette quatrième
journée monsieur paul laurent
secrétaires du comité central devait
ouvrir la discussion sur le projet de
résolution du congrès tandis que
monsieur charles fiterman également
secrétaire du comité central devait
présenter le rapport sur la réforme des
statuts de saint-point daniel grancher
mais aujourd'hui c'était la journée des
votes c'est à dire que les congressistes
ont adopté le rapport prononcé par
georges marchais il ya maintenant quatre
jours ils ont adopté à l'unanimité ce
qui n'est pas une surprise
deuxième vote le vote de la résolution
la résolution ce sont un peu les l'étape
de la loi qui vont servir de textes de
référence pendant les trois ans à venir
pour le parti communiste
là encore vote à l'unanimité a remarqué
quelques amendements qui sont intervenus
sur cette résolution et qui accentue
quelquefois les principales orientations
définies pendant le congrès union à la
base ou autogestion avec la création de
conseils d'ateliers dans toutes les
entreprises possible ce congrès dont ce
n'aura pas été marquée par la diversité
exceptionnelle des orateurs qui se sont
succédé à la tribune
la contestation ne semble pas à part une
intervention peut-être un peu critique
avoir franchi les murs du stade de
saint-denis où se tient ce congrès est
de toute façon cela encore été réaffirmé
cet après midi pour les partis
communistes il n'est pas question de
tendance
nous ne recherchons pas l'unanimité pour
l'unanimité l'accord pour l'accord nous
savons bien que dans les conditions de
notre lutte et s'agissant de la vie
sociale où de l'avis du parti
le monolithisme est illusoire ou
pernicieux s'il est considéré comme un a
priori nous avons appris de l'histoire
c'est justement pourquoi nous refusons
tout autant le désaccord pour le
désaccord les travailleurs tiennent à
l'unité de ce parti qui est le leur
et ils ont raison voilà pourquoi nous
repoussons les tendances et leur arsenal
de motion contradictoires de vote
marchand débloquer deux ténors
s'affrontant pour le partage des places
sur le devant de la scène
dans le même temps où se prépare en
coulisses les compromis voilà pourquoi
l'approbation quasi unanime du projet de
résolution l unité qu'elle exprime est
réelle profonde et vrai ce matin dans un
entretien avec quelques uns de nos
confrères nomadisme monsieur georges
marchais avait parlé des contestataires
au sein du parti
ce vent de contestation avec un
frémissement mais il existe a dit le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
en fait les contestataires n'assiste pas
au 23ème congrès du parti communiste
français un reportage de jean wilson
c'était avant-hier après-midi à paris
trois communistes français qui rentrent
de tchécoslovaquie expliquer à leurs
camarades ce qu'on appelle les
contestataires dupe et sait comment à
leur avis le pouvoir à prague porte
atteinte aux droits des citoyens
quelques heures plus tard les mêmes
contestataires se retrouvait devant
l'ambassade de tchécoslovaquie qui vous
tenté de déposer une gerbe et remettre
une pétition au diplôme à deux exemples
de l'activité de ces contestataires
les communistes critiques comme on les
appelle encore deux exemples qui leur
donne une certaine notoriété
d'autant plus
ces derniers temps ils n'ont pas lésiné
sur le nombre d'ouvragés qui l'ont
écrire les temps mandaté par personne
ils n'ont pas assisté au 23ème congrès
du parti à saint-ouen
cela leur importe peu car à leurs yeux
là où le parti communiste français
pratiquent le centralisme il n'ya plus
de véritable démocratie
on en prend beaucoup dans le parti
communiste le mot grand débat
démocratique et je ne crois pas qu'il
puisse y avoir de grand débat
démocratique à partir du moment où la
direction du parti donne des thèses les
installe confortablement dans les
cellules fait accompagner ces thèses de
dirigeants du parti à tous les échelons
c'est à dire que tous les débats se sont
passées en présence d'un dirigeant
petits ou grands du parti qui suivait
comme on dit la cellule où la section le
dirigeant étant de plus en plus élevés
en grade à partir du bas jusqu'au on ne
parle que des intellectuels
contestataires ça veut dire que les
autres ne conteste pas que vous voulez
en représentait absolument pas nous ne
représentons rien aucun de nous ne
représente rien que lui même il n'y a
pas de de chef à la contestation
il n'y a pas d'idée contestataires
dominante il y à un ensemble d'idées de
développement d'idées de théories de
tendance même de nuances
tout cela réuni ou pas réunies ou même
réuni d'une façon qu'on plus conflictuel
forme la contestation
il est difficile d'être contestataires
parce que ce n'est pas un mouvement
ce n'est pas un parti ce n'est pas une
tendance
c'est surtout un grand mouvement de
pensée qui s'est répandue à travers les
communistes dans les usines dans les
universités partout particulièrement
partie de la rupture de la gauche mais
avec toutes ces critiques pourquoi ne
pas quitter purement et simplement le
parti communiste mais parce que nous
sommes communiste et que le parti
communiste a une existence qui est
nécessaire à ce pib parti communiste
constitue l'opposition à cette société
de dépression à tous points de vue et de
décadence en un sens dans laquelle nous
vivons
que le parti communiste bien ou mal
selon les cas continuent à protéger à
aider à se solidariser avec les mêmes
nous sommes donc dans le parti
communiste qui est dans ce mouvement
d'opposition au pouvoir
mais d'un autre côté nous sommes à
l'intérieur du parti communiste opposés
à ceux qui de près ou de loin entravent
le cheminement vers un socialisme dans
la liberté
c'est à dire continue à marcher sur un
système purement stalinien le congrès ne
cfdt c'est d'acheter ce matin edmond
maire a été réélu au bureau confédéral
avec une majorité confortable
les trois quarts des suffrages exprimés
et il reste comme prévu
secrétaire-général monsieur jacques
chérèque remplace monsieur peillon comme
cela pèsera d'adjoint monsieur chérèque
qui est secrétaire général de
l'importante fédération de la
métallurgie
c'est dès la semaine prochaine qu'une
rencontre cgt cfdt prévu pour décider
d'une action commune en faveur de la
semaine des 35 élections européennes
monsieur jacques chirac insiste il a une
nouvelle fois demandé ce matin que
madame simone veil débattre en public
avec lui avant les élections européennes
monsieur chirac qui s'adressait aux
gaullistes de gauche du mouvement pour
le socialisme par la participation s'est
d'autre part étonnée et je le cite que
l'on cache comme si on avait honte
certains candidats de la liste
officielle gouvernementale fin de
citation je vous rappelle que monsieur
françois mitterrand a lui aussi proposé
un match sur l'écran à madame veil et à
propos de monsieur mitterrand
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste sera notre invité en direct
antenne de midi ce mercredi qui vient
monsieur raymond barre était ce matin en
italie voyage bref mais important le
premier ministre français a rencontré
son homologue italien monsieur andreotti
au cours des cérémonies marquant la fin
des travaux de percement du tunnel
routier du mont fréjus un tunnel de 12
km 500 qui reliera à modane en france au
village italien de bardonnèche à partir
de juillet 1981 et d'entrée de jeu
monsieur bart a tenu à placer cet
événement sous le signe de l'europe
elle avance en dépit des obstacles et je
dirais à cause les obstacles jolis
mouvements de va était la nature y
aurait au moins ici mais non à présent
nos choses ensemble les gens ont des
rochers au moment où la campagne aux
élections qui fâchent universel de
l'assemblée par le mans dernier
communauté envers je vous suis en pays
quel meilleur exemple que les otakus
d'europe que c'est l'entreprise du
courage et un sens salvador la situation
ne s'éclaircit pas l'ambassadeur de
france musique de modène et ses
collaborateurs sont toujours retenus en
otages
et voici maintenant plus d'une semaine
que cela dure les autorités de salvador
en relâcher deux des cinq hommes dont le
mouvement populaire révolutionnaire le
bpr exigeait la libération
mais en déclarant je dirais des
autorités qu'elles ignoraient tout des
trois autres personnes dont le vpn
demande que soient libérés en tout cas
le ppr a occupé une autre ambassade à
salvador celles du venezuela en iran a
commencé aujourd'hui le plus important
procès qui se soit déroulé devant un
tribunal du nouveau régime
cent quatorze prévenus sont accusés de
collaboration avec le régime déchu
le ton monte entre le président du milk
et repères et les députés américains
c'est à dire les membres de la chambre
des représentants
ces derniers ont rejeté le plan de
rationnement de l'essence du président
des états unis
monsieur carter leur ai dit carrément
vous êtes des irresponsables
vous ne pensez qu'à la satisfaction
immédiate des intérêts les plus étroits
de vos électeurs auxquels vous ne voulez
pas être désagréable en refusant le
rationnement et vous oubliez en fait
l'intérêt national des etats-unis et
monsieur carter a donné trois mois aux
députés pour proposer leurs propres
plans décodeur deux personnalités de
l'arabie saoudite pays grands
producteurs de pétrole comme vous avez
sont aujourd'hui même à paris le fils du
roi khaled le prince fahd homme fort du
régime est connue jusqu'à ces temps
derniers comme ayant un préjugé
particulièrement favorable à l'égard des
états unis
l'autre personnalité temps le prix
saoud al faiçal ministre des affaires
étrangères et qui passe par paris après
la conférence islamique de fès la visite
de ces deux hommes de tendances
différentes et qui seront demain les
autres à déjeuner du président de la
république paraît d'autant plus
importante que le refroidissement entre
washington et l'arabie saoudite est
sensible depuis le traité de paix
israélo égyptien dans son palais de ryad
l'émir fed prince héritier d'arabie
séoudite frère de l'ancien roi faysal et
de l'actuel souverain le roi khaled
reçoit chaque semaine les doléances des
bédouins et de tout citoyen d'arabie qui
souhaitent le voir il y a quelques mois
encore on l'appelait l'homme fort du
régime
le roi son frère malade et peu passionné
de politique
le laissait entièrement maîtres du jeu
le prince khaled était aussi l'homme des
américains il jouait un rôle modérateur
dans la politique pétrolière de son pays
et c'est lui qui avait signé l'accord
militaire entre l'arabie et les états
unis en 1974
mais aujourd'hui le clan débuts au sein
de la famille royale l'emportent sur le
sien qui était pourtant le plus puissant
la politique américaine au proche orient
l'accord de paix entre l'egypte et
israël patronné par washington
la chute du shah d'iran ont tout
bouleversé
l'arabie ne fait plus confiance à
l'amérique ni pour sa sécurité
ni pour la paix au proche orient les
nouveaux princes abandonne la politique
de docilité du prince fahed vis-à-vis de
washington et de l'occident il condamne
la politique de carter et freinent la
production de pétrole brut
chantage ou revirement total de
l'attitude séoudienne tout dépendra en
fait de la durée de l'effacement de
l'homme sur qui l'occident avait misé le
prince fahd d'arabie séoudite
avec ce en provence la cour d'assises
des bouches du rhône a condamné et
sébastien castelnau alias le mage qui
libéra mme à huit ans de réclusion
criminelle et à 10 ans d'interdiction de
séjour sport maintenant
nadia comaneci a remporté aujourd'hui à
copenhague le premier titre des finales
des championnats d'europe de gymnastique
par agrès le saut de cheval
les deux ligier partiront une nouvelle
fois en première ligne de mazel d'air
pour le grand prix formule 1 de belgique
puisque jacques laffite et réalisé le
meilleur temps sept dixièmes de seconde
devant un patrick dépailler football
finale de la coupe d'angleterre un match
fantastique que vous verrez demain dans
stade 2 arsenal a battu manchester par 3
à 2 à la dernière minute
demain à longchamp enverra dans le prix
du pain celui qui passe jusqu'à présent
pour être le meilleur cheval en france
d'année irish hiver quant au tiercé
il se dispute dans un handicap de très
longues distances quand 1300 mètres 23
partants la course s'appelle le prix
rieussec indique-t-on célèbre proclame
le prix rio sec mais le parieur asec
voilà maintenant pire est s'il vous
plaît vous propose exactement autant le
tiercé de dinan gerny été facile a
pronostiqué parce que les favoris
logiques était à l'arrivée autant demain
ça va être très dur alors ce sera un
gros tiers saint perspective avec
sûrement des outsiders à l'arrivée j'ai
choisi de placer en tête un cheval et
une écurie en forme avec white gold
entraînée par an ils vendent poule
malgré les deux dernières victoires de
ce cheval il n'est pénalisé il n'est pas
pénalisés ils ne portent que 48 kg donc
c'est très intéressant à suivre derrière
lui mon rôle je viens de faire une
course décevante mais il est en progrès
il doit pouvoir se rattraper ensuite
gone bad
il s'adapte à tous les terrains et la
langue licence lui plaît énormément
ça aussi c'est un avantage le vignau et
très à l'aise à longchamp surtout sur
une longue distance parce que c'est un
cheval d'un modèle important il est très
long à trouver son rythme pirro joxe son
entraîneur bernard cycliques crois moi
aussi sur le dur petit gueuleton
c'est très joli buzz tome il porte un
poids avantageux 47 kilos et demi et il
est en grande forme actuellement ensuite
il y avait le martin c'est un vrai
coureur de fond pour moi c'est
l'outsider idéal et pour terminer ses
lancers langston lta il devrait pouvoir
lui aussi se racheter sa dernière course
a été très malheureuse il a été vraiment
gêné pendant le parcours alors je vous
rappelle leur numéro 17 4 7 19 12 18 9
22 mai pour les vrais amateurs de
spotify hippiques il ne faudra pas
évidemment le prix lupin demain parce
que les thunes pour ce classique où
s'affronteront tous les meilleurs 3 ans
vous l'avez ni et mais pour la première
fois ils affronteront une longue
distance de 1600 mètres
et là il est intéressant de voir comment
va se comporter les riches river et tous
les autres parce qu'il ya aussi tom
ville old town qui est qu'ils sont très
très bon et shachtman voilà on rencontre
les images pour demain à l'édition de
grands acteurs woody allen et qui est il
que fait-il en dehors de son film bien
entendu en cette période de festival de
cannes france roche l'a évidemment
rencontré voici goudé allen interrogé
par transpole
le génie comique américain woody allen
au festival il rit un peu et pleure
beaucoup dans manhattan film en noir et
blanc où il cite les choses qui valent
que la vie soit vécue pêle-mêle groucho
marx et mozart un restaurant américain
et les pommes de cézanne l'éducation
sentimentale et le visage de son
interprète
mariel hemingway qui joue à ses côtés
avec meryl streep et diane keaton pour
vous dit la liste est courte
la vie est invivable c'est l'histoire de
ce qui arrive à la culture américaine
les relations entre êtres humains
deviennent de plus en plus difficile il
devient de plus en plus difficile d'être
honnête de ne pas se vanter et plus
difficile de tomber amoureux
parce que nous vivons en amérique dans
un environnement culturel dévasté par la
nourriture express télévision mauvaise
musique drogue
c'est dommage new york était une si
belle ville
elle doit lutter chaque jour contre
l'envahissement de la laideur qui
graduellement investi toutes les grandes
villes américaines
ça vient d'une culture qui n'a pas de
noyau spirituelle qui a l'argent
l'éducation mais aucun désir d'être en
paix avec le monde
aucun projet essentiel ils ne savent pas
ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils écoutent ils
n'ont aucun noyau religieux ou
philosophique
ils agissent de façon opportuniste sur
le coup sans aucune vue sur l'avenir
il veut faire vite de l'argent
s'anesthésier aussi au lieu de régler
les problèmes existants qui sont
compliquées il balaie la poussière sous
le tapis et s'absorbe dans le programme
télévisé prennent de la cocaïne
au fond ce qui peut leur permettre
d'échapper à aux confrontations avec les
réalités déplaisant vous êtes très
sérieux pour un génie comme lui je suis
sérieux mon problème quand je fais une
comédie ou canche et un film c'est
difficile pour moi de me mettre en état
d'être drôle
j'ai des amis comme mel brooks lui
trouve qu'il est difficile de ne pas
être drôle
il explose toutes les dix secondes
moi j'ai le problème inverse j'ai du mal
à trouver l'énergie pour jouer mon rôle
et few si une fée vous proposer de
choisir votre vie qu'elle nourrit et
vous faire si je pouvais vivre de la
façon que je préfère et si j'en avais le
talent je voudrais être pianiste
je pense que c'est la vie la puce a
grillé j'aimerais être dans la musique
j'aime la musique le classique le jazz
j'aimerais être rubinstein la météo pour
demain
après dissipation des brouillards et des
nuages qui seront assez nombreux le
matin en particulier sur la moitié nord
de la france
le temps sera ensoleillé l'après-midi et
les températures seront agréables
cependant des ondées orageuses sont à
craindre sur la corse l'extrême sud-est
je ne dis pas qu'elle
produiront elles sont seulement à
craindre restons optimistes
vers 23h15 hervé claude vous donnera les
dernières informations de la journée
demain le journal de la mi-journée à
13h15 et si tel est votre bon plaisir
nous retrouvons ici même à 20 heures
bonne soirée
merci